[Musik]
guten abend liebe zuschauer wir haben es
22 15 heute an diesem donnerstag wir
haben diese gäste und hier ist unser
thema hab ich's oder habe ich nicht
sicherheit bringt nur der test am besten
einen pcr-test aber genau die sind knapp
ausgerechnet jetzt wo wir sie so
dringend brauchen 200.000 neuinfektionen
heute sind ein neuer rekord wie viele
kommen noch wir wissen es immer weniger
in die politik vor dem kontrollverlust
letzte hoffnung impfpflicht wer in
kliniken oder im pflegeheim arbeitet der
sieht ihr der impfpflicht schon mitte
märz ins auge gilt sie bald für alle
darum gibt es streit wie eben auch um
das testen wieder nicht gemeinsam gegen
korona das fragen wir uns und diese
gäste
karl lauterbach der
bundesgesundheitsminister sagt wir
brauchen die impfpflicht gegen die
nächste welle
linda teuteberg von der fdp ist dagegen
eine kluge test strategie würde reichen
thorsten frei der cdu politiker sagt die
fdp dominiert die korona politik der
ampel
carsten watzl der immunologe stellt fest
jetzt stecken sich viele genesene und
geimpfte an
und frauke rostalsky die
rechtsprofessoren sagt es ist
erschreckend dass wir menschen nach
ihren impfstatus bewerten
sie sind zu gast bei maybrit illner und
die bewusst ausgesprochen herzlich alle
anwesenden und zugeschalteten gäste los
geht's wer hat sich angesteckt wer darf
wie der arbeiten um das einigermaßen
sicher beantworten zu können braucht man
tests aber wo sind die
erst die masken
dann der impfstoff
[Applaus]
jetzt die tests
die viertgrößte volkswirtschaft der welt
beweist wir können auch mangelwirtschaft
mittlerweile das dritte jahr in folge
erwischte es die politik eiskalt sorry
pcr tests nur noch für wohlhabende und
kritische infrastruktur
bei allen anderen reichen plötzlich
schnelltests
wir erinnern uns die anti gen tests
selbst wenn sie gut gemacht sind
entdecken nur ungefähr 60 prozent der
infizierten so die krone
die sind nicht so super um jede
infektion zu identifizieren wir wissen
nicht genau wie gut diese tests für
omicron wirken die neue test strategie
besser mangelverwaltung empört
patientenschützer eltern und lehrer
verband wenn es dann aber wirklich
darauf ankommt immer priorität
einzuräumen etwa bei der verteilung von
pcr tests dann fallen schulen immer
hinten über in wien kein problem zu
hause vor der kamera gurgeln und fertig
3,5 millionen pcr tests werden
wöchentlich in riesen laboren
ausgewertet mehr als in ganz deutschland
im europäischen vergleich liegen wir bei
pcr testungen gerade mal vor rumänien
ungarn und polen
[Musik]
das klingt überhaupt nicht gut karl
lauterbach ist bei uns der
bundesgesundheitsminister vor einem
halben jahr herr lauterbach waren diese
schnelltests noch nicht mal gut dazu
sich für einen krankenbesuch frei zu
testen und jetzt sollen sie uns aus
einer infektion naja sondern ganz so
schlecht sind die des auf keinen fall
ich komme gleich dazu was die test
leisten wo sie gut sind wo sie nicht so
gut sind aber in der tat ist es so also
wenn man also mehr pcs machen will die
pcs werden ja von privaten laboren
angeboten die also uns nicht gehören die
wir nicht also sein
ja die wir nicht koordinieren können die
werde ich befehligen können dann also
muss man also sehr früh ein anderes
verfahren aufbau das was man in wiegen
aufgebaut hat das sind so genannte
pulling testpool pcr-test pcs es
funktioniert einfach so dass wir beim
konsumieren wir bleiben jetzt hier in
deutschland
wird nur trotzdem erklären dann können
sie nicht da sind genau und zwar damals
also wie gesagt keine parteipolitik kann
also keine schuldzuweisungen aber damals
gab es wissenschaftler vor anderthalb
jahren ich war einer davon die haben
gesagt das müssen wir deutschland
aufbauen können größere wellen bekommen
simonazzi sich hat ist glaube ich
erfunden ja sagen hat dem saarland ist
es also gibt es eine forschungsgruppe es
gibt eine sehr gute show
forschungsgruppe hier an der charité das
anders er hat das gemacht und wir hatten
sogar den damaligen
bundesgesundheitsminister ein vorschlag
immer wie man so was aufbauen kann und
damals haben wir uns aber für den
antigen test stattdessen entschied so
kann der das ersetzen was der pcr test
jetzt nicht mehr kann weil wir ihn nicht
haben brauchen wir zwei von denen wir
noch was wir jetzt machen werden es ganz
einfach also wir haben also gruppen in
der bevölkerung da muss ich das ergebnis
sehr schnell haben zum beispiel wenn
jemand so in der realisierung medicine
arbeit und so muss ich sogar sofort
wissen hat der ist eher positiv oder
nicht oder beispielsweise bei jemandem
der viele risikofaktoren hatte und wo
ich dann entscheiden muss kann ich den
mit parcours wird beispielsweise
behandeln dann muss ich auch sehr
schnell das ergebnis habe aber bei den
anderen sind die anti gen test
eigentlich auch sehr gut weil ich wenn
die für den fall dass die wirklich so
stark angesteckt sind dass sie andere
wiederum anstecken da ist der antigen
testen der regel positiv so mittig über
sehe damit den einen oder anderen in der
früheren infektions phase aber dann sind
die menschen oft nicht so stark
infiziert dass sie andere schon
ansteckend somit darf man den antigen
test jetzt nicht kaputt reden
wie gesagt ich habe damals ein anderes
verfahren vorgegeben oder vorgeschlagen
aber ich glaube dass wir auch mit dem
was wir jetzt haben und deutschland hat
sehr viel an tigers eine gute medizin
messen kann sagt der
bundesgesundheitsminister bei uns ist
karsten ratzke monologe professor an der
uni dortmund generalsekretär der
deutschen gesellschaft für immunologie
wir sind in näher bei rumänien und nicht
bei österreich was machen die
österreicher besser schlechter
und warum haben wir tatsächlich wieder
von einer sache die wir sehr dringend
brauchen zu wenig na gut ich meine
bisher hatten wir genug jetzt haben wir
natürlich bei diesen hohen instanzen
haben wir auf einmal nicht mehr genug
das muss man ganz klar sagen ich sehe
natürlich auch das xoom pcr test nichts
ist was man mal eben so die kapazität
verdoppeln kann da sind spezielle geräte
gefragt also und reagenzien gefragt da
haben wir selbst im labor wenn wir auch
forschung betreiben probleme teilweise
diese ergänzung zu bekommen weil die
knapp sind und was auch knapp ist es
natürlich leute die das bedienen können
also es ist natürlich jetzt in der
situation wo wir jetzt gerade sind sehr
schwer mal eben die kapazität zu
verdoppeln weil ich einfach die
personalien und die geräte nicht habe
das hätte ich natürlich vielleicht im
vorfeld mehr aufbauen können dass
darüber kann man sich glaube ich
streiten aber jetzt in der situation
glaube ich gut kann man sehr wenig
machen muss man leider sagen es sei denn
wir würden auf solche tests umsteigen wo
man dann einfach mit einem test zehn
leute oder acht leute testen kann wobei
die zahl wird auch immer kleiner je
höher die inzidenz ist so ist das masken
pcr test den wir uns schnelltests damals
sind die sachen immer nur dann wichtig
wenn sie auch zur verfügung haben
nein also ich glaube um vielleicht auch
mal das ein bisschen noch noch weiter zu
bringen ich glaube die pcr test im
moment sind gar nicht so das problem wo
ich eher das problem sind auch
perspektivisch ist dass wir noch in der
datenlage generell ein problem haben was
wir wissen und was wir nicht wissen also
wo ich moment das große problem sehe ist
dass wir jetzt über neun millionen
infizierte haben wahrscheinlich die
dunkelziffer doppelt so hoch als 20
millionen menschen dann wahrscheinlich
diese infektion durchgemacht in
deutschland und wir wissen gar nicht wer
das ist und ob diese personen sich haben
doch mal impfen lassen oder oder nicht
also ich glaube da fehlt uns schon
beispielsweise auch diese antigene
schnelltest natürlich zählen wenn die
jetzt anstelle von pcr tests verbannt
werden um eben weder ist nur eines
sicher stellen ok jetzt würde sich
bestimmt also das mahlgut jetzt kommt
die frage an thorsten frei die gesamte
union herr frey erster parlamentarischer
geschäftsführer
der gesamten fraktion ihr würde doch
empört skandal rufen wenn die erinnerung
an den gesundheitsminister entspannen
nicht so frisch wäre oder nee das würde
ich nicht sagen ich mein mann muss
glaube ich wirklich in rechnung stellen
in dieser pandemie sind immer auch
fehler gemacht worden es ist immer dazu
gelernt worden und das muss man jedem
nicht mehr skandal das muss
jeder der über dieses thema spricht muss
das glaube ich mit einbeziehen aber es
gibt schon ein paar dinge die sind
wichtig ich glaube in der jetzigen phase
der pandemie ist es ganz entscheidend
den menschen auch ein stückweit
planungssicherheit zu geben
das ist sicherlich schwierig in einer
pandemie aber man muss es wenigstens
versuchen und wenn sie die pcr tests
ansprechen da ist es tatsächlich so dass
omikron bereits am 26 november von der
weltgesundheitsorganisation als
besonders besorgniserregende variante
identifiziert wurde herr lauterbach hat
auch an vielen stellen darauf
hingewiesen was da auf uns zukommt und
dann ist es natürlich schon seltsam wenn
das
bundesgesundheitsministerium noch am 10
januar sagt wir planen nicht die test
kapazitäten aus und genau das ist die
frage erneut alba das so nicht gesagt
aber ihr haushalt
des körper zu tun hier kommt die frage
ganz kurz nur vage lautet herr
lauterbach wenn sie seit november
apostrophieren was jetzt eingetreten ist
nämlich dass wir sechsstellig infizierte
haben
infizierten zahlen haben hätte man da
nicht viel früher einen pcr kapazität
ausbauen müssen wir haben alles gemacht
was wir hatten bisher kapazität von 2,4
millionen dann haben wir alles gemacht
was man konnte um das auf 2,8 millionen
auszudehnen aber er war zu bestätigen
dass der pcr kann nur gemacht wenn von
leuten die dafür ausgebildet sind
akkreditiert sind das sind private
labore die reagenz insel nicht da der
oder der also anlass also es gibt eine
spezielle agents die ich brauche um das
verfahren überhaupt in schwung zu
bringen es fehlt also wert weiter und so
schlecht sind wir nicht das will ich
doch auch mal sagen also wir haben ja
jetzt haben wir 200 tausend fälle am tag
aber bis zum jetzigen zeitpunkt haben
wir tatsächlich alles noch über den pcr
machen können das keine kleinigkeit aber
er sollte und wie lange die menschen
darauf gewartet haben herr lauterbach
sie wissen dass die drei tage dieses
testergebnis abgewartet haben wie lange
die schlangen sind das muss ich ihnen
alles nicht sagen es ist eine ganz
andere situation
jetzt hat er frei also darauf
hingewiesen was ich hätte machen können
ganz offen gesagt also die die das
wassersystem noch hergab ein privates
system also ein labor verband das sind
total lebens würdige kluge leute mit
denen habe ich mich sofort zusammen
gesetzt haben sagt kommt lasst uns
zusammen sitzen was ist das maximum die
aldi a m das wäre bestellt wird nämlich
zu sagen dass da was ist das maximum wir
spielen hier im gleichen fallen was ist
das maximum was wir rausholen können was
braucht er damit unter anderem und da
war nur möglich also 400.000 mehr und
dann gibt es so etwas ähnliches wie den
pc an den pocket aces ähnlich genau da
haben wir die vergütung jetzt verbessert
und mit eur auf verhandelt dass die
katholischen kommen holen wir noch mal
in der woche 250.000 nacken das ist auch
ein pcr test muss der zuschauer sich
merken weil dann vielleicht nicht den
hat heute berg ist bei uns die so nicht
nur endlich zu wort kommen sondern für
die fdp auch sprechen sie sind freute
berg nicht ein großer fan der
impfkampagne der impfpflicht das darf
ich schon mal sagen und sagen testen
würde uns helfen mit einer guten test
strategie kämen wir auch vielleicht um
eine impfpflicht herum braucht man dafür
nicht um protest also richtig ist dass
ich mit gemeinsam mit anderen
kolleginnen und kollegen ein antrag
gegen eine allgemeine impfpflicht
einbringen allerdings ist es nicht so
dass ich sagen würde wie sie gerade mein
spieler gebracht haben eine test
strategie allein würde reichen ich finde
da würde ich an frei zustimmen muss in
der pandemie dazulernen und dazu gehört
finde ich nach zwei jahren pandemie
spätestens mal dass das entweder oder
denken teil des problems ist wir
brauchen beides wir brauchen und wenn
sie sagen impfkampagne ich bin sehr für
impfkampagne übrigens für eine die kopf
und herz erreicht und ich finde da ist
viel luft nach oben in deutschland
stelle nicht die mal mit der in
frankreich vergleiche etwa ich bleibe
allerdings dabei dass
auch etwas was ich für sinnvoll und
vernünftig halte und die impfung ist ein
segen sie ist für die allermeisten
erwachsenen der beste schutz vor einem
schweren ko witt 19 verlauf und deshalb
ist es gut wenn sich möglichst viele
menschen impfen lassen ich halte aber
eine allgemeine impfpflicht für das
falsche instrument dafür und sage dass
eine zum beispiel kluge test strategie
genug möglichst soweit es irgend geht
kapazitäten dafür auch ein wichtiger
teil der strategie ist wir haben aber
oft eine schwarz weiß debatte bei der
nur gesagt hat entweder wir im herbst
noch die impfung allein bringt ein ende
der pandemie grund spätestens lehrt
etwas anderes wir brauchen auch weiter
testen und andere maßnahmen und
vorausschauende politik bedeutet
übrigens auch zum beispiel nicht ständig
von gerichten korrigiert werden zu
müssen oder die nötigen kapazitäten
vorzuhalten und so gibt es vieles mehr
als wir sollten das nicht gegeneinander
ausspielen sondern einsatz für das
impfen muss eben nicht bedeuten für eine
impfpflicht zu sein und auch als
juristin sage ich wir müssen da mildere
und bessere mittel haben und da ist
längst nicht alle reden wir auf jeden
fall noch diskutieren wir bleiben noch
eine sekunde er erwarte bei dieser frage
kann man in bezug auf das testen weil es
die menschen natürlich jetzt sofort
betritt und weil es das tägliche leben
organisiert kann man wirklich sagen zwei
antigen schnelltests sind so gut wie ein
pcr wenn man sich frei testen möchte
wenn man sich frei testen möchte geht es
ja im prinzip darum ob man noch
ansteckend ist oder nicht und dann
trifft genau das zu was er gesagt hat
wenn ich wirklich noch sehr viel
viruslast habe sind die anti gen test
gar nicht so schlecht weil sie dann in
den meisten fällen wirklich anschlagen
und ich darf mich ja auch erst frei wenn
ich wirklich zwei tage keine symptome
mehr habe das heißt es gibt ja länder
die einfach nur ohne test sogar sagen in
den usa kann nicht ohne tests nach einer
gewissen zeit einfach raus wenn ich zwei
tage keine symptome mehr habe das heißt
die gefahr die davon ausgeht dass einer
zwei tage symptomfrei ist und ein zwei
negativen test hat und dann immer noch
infektiös ist die so gering ich glaube
das risiko kann man eingehen schön wäre
natürlich ein pcr test aber ich glaube
das ist es nicht das nächstbeste dingen
hier sind bei frau rostalsky frage
rostalsky mitglied im deutschen ethikrat
rechtswissenschaftlerin die ich in köln
sehr herzlich begrüße vor rostalsky
jetzt ist interessant zu bemerken und
auch zu verstehen dass natürlich jeder
in so einer situation wo nicht
priorisiert sondern er rationiert wird
den finger gehoben hat und sagt ich
möchte bitte auch priorisiert werden es
melden sich eltern es melden sich lehrer
es melden sich patienten angehört es
melden sich wir könnten es verlängern
was sagt die juristin entscheidet man da
ja guten abend zunächst für meiner seite
das problem mit der priorisierung kennen
wir jetzt schon auch aus anderen
zusammenhang das hatten sie im
einspieler ja schon gesagt im kontext
der impfung haben wir das am anfang ja
auch entscheiden müssen wen wir zunächst
impfen können lassen und so müssen wir
hier eben jetzt auch wieder klare
kriterien entwickeln und ein
entscheidendes kriterium ist dabei eben
in dieser pandemie in welcher weise
können wir haben besten leib und leben
schützen und wenn es jetzt um die
zuteilung von pcr tests geht stehen da
sicherlich ganz oben all diejenigen die
unmittelbaren kontakt zu den
risikogruppen haben sowohl nach ob in
gruppen haben also menschen in
krankenhäusern in pflegeeinrichtungen
auch die angehörigen von risiko also
diejenigen die selbst zur risikogruppe
dazu gehören spielen hier eine
entscheidende rolle und das vor dem
hintergrund den der herr
bundesgesundheitsminister gerade genannt
hat wenn es darum geht frühzeitig ein
medikament zu erhalten das dann noch den
entscheidenden schritt zur genesung
beitragen kann dann spielt das eben auch
eine große rolle gerade bei dieser
besonders wohlfühlen gruppe aber
selbstverständlich müssen wir die
anderen gruppen nicht aus dem blick
verlieren das problem mit der verteilung
von knappen gütern ist dass am ende des
tages aber eben doch eine reihenfolge
gefunden werden muss wo der oder die
eine oder andere dann erst nachrangig
berücksichtigt werden kann das ist ein
unschöner zustand eine große aufregung
herr lauterbach gab es auch um die
genesenen und die johnson geimpften die
müssen jetzt auch ganz viel getestet
werden weil die sind plötzlich aus ihrem
status herausgefallen hat sie das lka
überrascht oder wollten sie die
ministerpräsidenten auch ein bisschen
überrumpelt sich überrumpeln niemanden
das habe ich gesagt nicht nötig solchen
und meine art wir haben noch alle
überraschen dass online auch nicht so
kann man es auch nicht sagen aber wir
hatten also sehr intensiv daran
gearbeitet
wie wir die regeln für quarantäne
ihre kontaktpersonen und isolation
infizierte wie wir die ändern wer ist
also sozusagen ausgenommen von der
isolation wäre es ausgenommen von der
karte in daran hatten wir sehr intensiv
gearbeitet parallel lief auf
arbeitsebene auch einer diskussion für
wie lange gilt jemand allgemein für
genießen also jetzt unabhängig von der
isolation oder von der quarantäne und
diese diskussionen da dachte ich die wir
noch nicht abgeschlossen dass wir das
später entscheiden werden und das ist
aber dann offenbar also auch an diesem
abend auch an diesem abend entschieden
worden und das ist eine also ja
kommunikationsfehler ist und gewesen
dass mich hatte diese entscheidung
erfuhr wie fühlt sich die persönlichen
vergangenheit haseloff sagt sie hätten
die wissenschaft instrumentalisieren das
ist aber das habe ich sowieso nicht weil
also ich finde den beschluss sehr
wichtig und von daher habe ich die
wissenschaft also einfach nur
bestätigt und ich habe auch keinen
politischen einfluss auf den beschluss
also genommen im
profi hat glaube ich also angenommen
dass ich zu dem zeitpunkt wo ich mit ihm
über die anderen regeln gesprochen habe
hatcher andeuten sollen genau dass ich
das schon gewusst hätte dass also der
riesen status ganz allgemein und das war
nicht der fall ist ja doch ich das sagen
ich hätte auch keinen grund gehabt
ehrlich gesagt dann beruflich da nicht
zu informieren ich wusste nicht dass das
zu dem zart von roberto zu dem zeitpunkt
vom robert-koch-institut auch schon auf
die seite kommt muss aber dazu sagen die
entscheidung selbst diese drei monate
die finden sie noch nicht richtig das
ist somit also ist das also ist das
vielleicht ein oder zwei tage oder drei
tage früher auf die seite des robert
koch instituts kommt als ich mir
gewünscht hätte es macht weiter
kommuniziert werden er muss auch besser
begründet werden es gibt menschen die
sagen da konnte der herr lauterbach doch
die impfquote noch ein bisschen erhöhen
indem man das sind spekulationen das
sind sind also
wir haben märchen sind das in dem sinne
zunächst einmal also wenn der also
genesenen status also verkürzt ist muss
das medizinisch begründet sein und der
medizinische grund ist einfach die komik
und variante gefällt viele die schon mal
mit der data variante infiziert waren
und auch sogar viele die mit der data
variante infiziert waren und geimpft
waren zu gehen also es geht einfach so
darüber und wegen der hohen ansteckung
durch die omikron feierte ist hier
genießen den status von jantscher bonis
gesundheitsminister aber jetzt muss man
doch eines sehen also das hat ja alles
konsequenzen und ich finde da stehen
jetzt die ministerpräsidenten mit
verlaub gar nicht im mittelpunkt sondern
ich denke mal an die bürger zum beispiel
an diejenigen die sich dann testen
müssen am arbeitsplatz an diejenigen die
dann nicht mehr in geschäfte einkaufen
gehen können an diejenigen die
urlaubsreisen absagen müssen und zwar
von einem tag auf den anderen und
deswegen finde ich ist es nicht nur eine
kommunikationspanne sondern das ist auch
etwas was ein stück weit vertrauen
zerstört weil menschen von einem tag auf
den anderen vor eine völlig neue
situation gestellt werden und der zweite
punkt wenn ich das noch sagen darf ist
das ist die nachvollziehbarkeit ich mein
so was muss man kommunizieren und so was
muss man begründen und zur
nachvollziehbarkeit ich stelle mir auch
vor die dauer des genießen entstand
zeitpunkt das muss man doch
wissenschaftlich medizinische herr frey
dann kann es ja nicht sein auf der
europäischen ebene etwas anderes gilt
als in deutschland und in brehna saal
des deutschen bundestages gilt wieder
etwas andere wahl lassen wir dagegen
halten also war es eine wichtige debatte
ist also die ich gebe ja ich habe mir
ein dass man das besser kommunizieren
sollte aber er ist auch sehr viel
parteipolitik ich bin dass an dem
folgenden beispiel wir haben ja an dem
gleichen tag ohne jede vorbereitung ohne
jede vorankündigung haben wir also
regeln gemacht wo es darum ging dass
diejenigen die also
jetzt gebucht sind dass die nicht mehr
in das gericht ist garantiert ohne jede
vorbereitung neben angemerkt hat ja die
leute nicht vorbereiten und das kommt
plötzlich und sogar das wurde das kann
mir auch übernommen es ist der genesene
status der denjenigen
die im prinzip das falsch finden zu kurz
ist und daher ist die medea ist die
kritik nur gekommen zu dem punkt genesen
status das andere war ja auch nicht vor
angekündigt da habe ich überhaupt keine
kritik bekommen war das wurde gilt
massive gesehen als er die fragen noch
mal ganz schnell er frei ist wie finden
sie die entscheidungen selber in der
kommunikation falsch oder sagen sie
eigentlich müssen wir zu den sechs
monaten wieder zurück weil die
europäische union empfiehlt es jetzt
allen ländern und dann ist nur
deutschland noch der ausnahmen tiger
also der richtige zeitraum kann ich
ehrlicherweise als jurist nicht
beurteilen aber ich würde es für falsch
halten wenn wir in deutschland einen
sonderweg gehen würden ich glaube da
muss man die gleichen kriterien in der
europäischen union haben und das zweite
was mich irritiert der herr lauterbach
sagt dass drei monate die richtige zeit
werden die bundesregierung hat in europa
die hand gehoben also das
außenministerium zwar für sechs monate
und da muss man natürlich schon auch
erwarten können dass die bundesregierung
einheitlich agiert denn alles ein
bisschen untereinander aber auch ein
vertreter der bewegung gehören sekunde
sie sind gleich erklären noch mal ganz
ruhig auch
wir erklären noch mal ganz kurz
genesenen zustand ist das in der sache
richtig zu sagen wir wissen im grunde
genommen dass diese sechs monate zu groß
gegriffen sind oder wissen es nicht und
die schweiz wird sich dann auch mit
ihren zwölf monaten was wissen wir
wissenschaftlich muss man zwei dinge
unterscheiden also wenn ich die
infektion durchgemacht habe bin ich
immun ich bin geschützt nicht ganz so
gut wie jemand der jetzt zweimal geimpft
ist das muss man ganz klar sagen und
omikron hat die regeln verändert das
heißt bei omikron weil sich das virus so
verändert hat passen viele der
antikörper die ich gemacht habe nicht
mehr so gut auf das virus und deshalb
brauche ich viel mehr davon und wirklich
gut geschützt zu sein das heißt als
genesener ja kann es mir passieren dass
ich nicht nach drei monaten wieder an
stärke was dann aber ist ich bin nicht
mehr so gut geschützt vor der infektion
ich bin aber immer noch relativ gut
geschützt vor einem schweren verlauf und
wenn man sagt dass omikron die regeln
verändert hat und deshalb habe ich auch
ein problem mit dieser regelung gerade
dann hat die regel natürlich auch für
die geimpften verändert das heißt einer
jemand der nur in anführungszeichen zwei
impfungen bekommen hat steht nach drei
monaten ähnlich schlecht da im bezug auf
einer infektion mit omikron wie jemand
der nur genesen ist und deshalb sei man
auch nicht mehr unterscheiden zwischen
genau und der chef kann man vielleicht
sagen gut ich verkürze den genesenen
status auf drei monate für jemand der
nur die infektion durchgemacht hat aber
dann müsste ich in konsequenterweise
eigentlich auch den impfstatus für die
leute die nur zwei mal drei monate
verhindern
medizinische fragen hat einfach ganz
groß wir sind noch mal der fall die
sitzt rechts neben ihnen und sagt dann
nochmal die gleiche frage wie verhält
man sich politisch wie würde die fdp
sich verhalten in dieser frage alle auf
die sechs monate werden sie versuchen
karl lauterbach zu überzeugen dass es
nicht sein kann dass die europäische
union was anderes macht sogar das
deutsche aussenministerium was anderes
sagt in der eu und wie liebe alle bei
den sechs monaten bleiben oder werden
sie sich mit der regierung auf die drei
verständige ich würde erstmal insofern
ist das bei mir ähnlich wie bei hand
frei als juristin ich maße mir nicht an
selber jetzt die medizinischen dinge
beurteilen zu können was mir aber
auffällt und das finde ich eine wichtige
frage ist auch übrigens um vertrauen zu
gewinnen in der bevölkerung für für
notwendige maßnahmen was herr wetzel
gerade richtig sagt die erkenntnisse
sind ja interessant sie lassen auch
rückschlüsse auf die auf die dauer des
schutzes bei geimpften zu und mir fällt
auf dass oft sozusagen der ruf nach dem
erfolg der wissenschaft oder hört auf
die wissenschaft fast immer nur
einseitig benutzt wird unglücklich
starke restriktionen möglichst starke
grundrechtseingriffe oder sozusagen hier
da nur kurze zeiträume die als als
schutzdauer für den genesenen status
oder den impfstatus herhalten heißt es
wird immer nur in die richtung gemacht
hätte ich mal sozusagen möglichst starke
eingriffe zu rechtfertigen was wir noch
brauchen ist nachvollziehbarkeit auch
planbarkeit für all die bürgerinnen und
bürger die die sich vernünftig verhalten
die bereit sind sich an notwendiger
nachvollziehbare regeln und maßnahmen zu
halten aber die auch planbarkeit
brauchen deshalb auch möglicherweise ein
bisschen mehr vorbereitung und umsetzung
umsetzungsfristen sinnvoll sind wenn
herr lauterbach gerade erläutert hat das
offen dass er andere wichtige fragen am
gleichen abend entschieden wurden dann
ist mir aber schon aufgefallen dass es
da vorher mehr berichterstattung und
öffentliche debatte darüber gab also
dass den leuten bewusst war über ich für
das thema quarantäne zeiten wird gerade
verhandelt ich muss mich vielleicht
drauf einstellen und ich glaube einfach
da müssen wir aufpassen damit wir für
die nötigen massnahmen vertrauen und
akzeptanz haben und weil es auch mal so
sagen einer der größten freiheits killer
sozusagen auch unter unter pandemie
bedingung ist ungewissheit und sich
nicht einstellen können wie man auch
unter pandemie bedingungen
verantwortlich sein beruf ausüben kann
oder die bildung für die kinder
sicherstellen kann also deshalb brauchen
wir schon gute kommunikation und
rechtzeitige komponiert ist tatsächlich
herr frey hat es nur angedeutet und
haben die abgeordneten im deutschen
bundestag herr kubicki vorne ran dafür
plädiert dass es bei den sechs monaten
für die bundestagsabgeordneten bliebe
also so ist die immunität der
abgeordneten zu genießen sicherlich
nicht gemeint gewesen würden sie auch da
sagen der bundestag sollte sich
anschließen sechs monate herr kubicki
hat recht oder 3 ich finde wir sollten
grundsätzlich gleiche regelungen haben
für alle bürgerinnen und bürger musste
ich nur schnell nachfragen lauterbach
sie sind dran ja dazu kommen so viele
sachen zusammen also ich fange mal die
medizinischen mit dem was
medizinisch nicht entscheiden ich muss
einfach sagen aber dass ein
medizinischer ist ganz klar der also
genesenen status wenn ich meine wegen
also im um weihnachten eine data
infektion hatte dann kann ich jetzt an
der optik und infektion bekommen und das
müssen die bürger wissen und das ist die
grundlage der entscheidung fürs
robert-koch-institut gewesen das ist der
grund gewesen weshalb wir uns auf
europäischer ebene medizin nicht auch
dafür eingesetzt haben auch das glück
bundesgesundheitsministerium sie das
genau und ich muss das ja auch vertreten
also ich hab die fachaufsicht das robert
koch institut das muss ich also mit
vertreten und also beim auswärtigen amt
da geht es um reise regelungen das ist
eine andere baustelle aber wir haben das
mittig und nicht via bundesregierung
ganz kurz sagen darf und wir hatten wir
werden als bundesgesundheitsministerium
auf europäischen ebene auch weiter uns
dafür einsetzen dass der status auf drei
monate gekommen wird weil es medizinisch
wichtig ist dass die bürger das wissen
jetzt hat der fahrzeuge sagt was was
gilt denn dann für diejenigen die
geimpft sind und da muss sich
unterscheiden sind die drei mal geimpft
oder sind die doppelt gibt es da einmal
geimpft und ich stimme ihnen zu dass
eigentlich die grundimmunisierung eine
dreifache im wilden großmacht da sind
wir einer meinung so lese ich ihre
wissenschaftliche einlassung und ich
sehe es ganz genauso und das ist ein
unabhängiges thema daran muss
aufgearbeitet werden aber hier ging es
einfach schlicht nur um was ist der
genesenen status und der genesen status
da kann ich sagen das sind sechs monate
wenn ich weiß dass die menschen sich
nach drei monaten wieder infizieren
können daher habe ich die entscheidung
des robert-koch-instituts mitgetragen
und ich finde das muss man trennen
und man darf das nicht irgendwie
parteipolitik zu sein ich okay wir sind
dann trotzdem bei der frage breit dass
dem minister alleingänge vorgeworfen
werden und dann macht aber markus söder
sofort ein ding alleine und legt fest
dass er die fußballstadien gerne wieder
voll haben möchte und das jetzt zweig in
den restaurants nicht mehr haben möchte
versteht das eigentlich der bürger noch
ich glaube schon dass das ein großes
problem ist das ist ja eigentlich immer
der sind auch der sitzungen der
ministerpräsidenten mit dem
bundeskanzler und früher der
bundeskanzlerin gewesen dass man eine
gewisse einheitlichkeit dort wo es
sinnvoll ist bei den massnahmen erreicht
weil das einfach auch die
nachvollziehbarkeit erhöht die
transparenz die glaubwürdigkeit der
maßnahmen und deswegen würde ich immer
dafür plädieren bei allem respekt vor
föderalen lösungen dass man auch
versucht auf gemeinsame probleme
gemeinsam zu reagieren weil das die
glaubwürdigkeit erhöht und damit
natürlich die menschen dass auch er
beherzigen werden und umsetzen werden
und deswegen sehe ich das immer kritisch
wenn einzelne dann besondere regelungen
haben insbesondere dann wenn es die
regionalen unterschiede nicht her aber
es gibt ja nahrung für diese these dass
nikon eben nicht mehr ganz so gefährlich
nicht mehr diese ganz schweren
krankheitsverläufe induziert
er warte und das hört man nicht nur von
anderen wissenschaftlern sondern man
hört es auch aus anderen ländern von
anderen regierungen da wissen wir wohl
zu differenzieren aber braucht es jetzt
wirklich eine neue strategie und eine
neue wachsamkeit und achtsamkeit oder
können wir an manchen stellen
tatsächlich und wenn unter welchen
bedingungen laufen lassen die leute
wären ja verrückt jetzt kommt diese neue
b 2 variante muss man da jetzt noch viel
aufgeregter und sorgenvoller sein oder
muss man es eben nicht und in welche
richtung kann die politik jetzt auch ein
bisschen locker lassen also ja man muss
ganz klar sagen omikron ist jetzt
erstmal harmloser weil wir sehen ja
aktuell wir haben ihre hohe intelligenz
des events wie noch nie hatten und die
krankenhäuser sind noch einigermaßen
okay und auf den intensivstationen geht
es jetzt nicht mehr runter bleibt
stagniert muss man gucken was passiert
man muss aber jetzt wirklich ganz klar
sagen der hauptgrund warum omikron
harmloser es ist weil sich jetzt auch
die impfte und genesene anstecken können
weil einfach der schutz vor der
infektion nicht mehr so gut ist der
schutz vor der schweren erkrankung ist
bei diesen leuten aber noch da und
deshalb stecken sich sehr viele leute an
aber werden nicht schwer krank und der
zweite grund ist wenn wir auf die
inzidenz und gucken im moment tobt sich
das virus ganz klar bei den fünf- bis 29
jährigen aus also bei den jungen bei den
jungen die so besuchten relativ geringes
risiko haben schwer zu erkranken diese
diese mikrowelle ist noch nicht wirklich
zum glück bei den über 60-jährigen
angekommen da haben wir instanzen von
200 knapp 300 das heißt da müssen wir
wirklich wachsam sein wenn diese wenn
dir wirklich meine incident von 1000 bei
den über 60 jährigen haben dann haben
wir auch wieder probleme im
gesundheitssystem auch wenn auch micro
ein harmloser ist ja weil für einen
ungeimpften ist omikron nur so ungefähr
zu 25% harmlos im vergleich zu einer
delta infektion das heißt es ist immer
noch kein schnupfen virus und wir können
jetzt auch nicht einfach mal so laufen
wird so und wir sind bei frau rostalsky
in köln sie müssen uns helfen wieder bei
der erklärung für den normalen bürger
die dinge zu verstehen bleiben wir beim
fußball das versteht jeder der erste fc
köln fragt in richtung politik würfeln
die da eigentlich also man darf 200
zuschauer in hamburg haben man darf 750
in köln haben und 1000 in mainz herr
söder haben wir jetzt verfolgt kämpft
die 25.000 zurück und würfeln die da
eigentlich ist die entscheidende frage
kann politik ein solches angebot als
strategie verkaufen
vielleicht darf ich vorab noch einmal
kurz was zum genesenen status sagen weil
ich finde das passt auch gut zu der
jetzt von ihnen gestellten frage und es
lässt sich daran ganz gut
veranschaulichen dass die herabsetzung
auf drei monate und auch die bestimmung
dessen ob es sechs monate sein sollen
durchaus eine normative frage ist denn
wir müssen uns die frage stellen was
wollen wir denn mit dieser maßnahme
erreichen dass wir es auf drei monate
runtersetzen und wenn ich herrn
lauterbach so zuhöre dann gewinne ich
den eindruck dass es ihm darum geht die
infektion als solche zu vermeiden sagt
der bürger muss wissen dass er sich
anstecken kann gleichzeitig sagt herr
wachse über die drei monate hinaus
besteht noch schutz vor schweren
verläufen wir sind uns alle einig dass
es bei den pandemie schutzmaßnahmen
darum geht schwere verläufe zu vermeiden
damit die intensivstationen entlastet
bleiben und dann ist es eben doch schon
entscheidender punkt wenn man sagt nach
drei monaten ist
wegen sechs monate das muss dann
erwarten die genaue zahl noch nennen
wenn er das kann aber in jedem fall
darüber hinaus noch schutz für die
intensivstation dann ist es eben doch
ein problem zu sagen wir setzen das
runter auf drei monate weil es eben
nicht bloß darum geht infektionen zu
vermeiden sondern es geht darum intensiv
statt des lenkers mehr in lauterbach
dass so etwas sagt der sehr wichtiger
punkt ich bin dankbar dass sie den
aufbringen derjenige der nach drei
monaten sich infiziert der infiziert
dann meinetwegen die 80 jährige
großmutter oder mutter und die verstärkt
an das heißt die gesamte ich muss dass
die ketten immer ich muss die kette
baten also wenn ich tatsächlich den
medizinischen schutz in den vordergrund
stellen die überlastung der in den
intensiv kapazitäten und zweitens vor
dann muss nicht schauen dass wir die
wellen nicht in die hohen altersgruppen
schlägt was bisher ja nicht passiert ist
und wenn werden wir über den älteren
instanzen über 1000 bekommen dann
bekommen wir ein riesenproblem auch mit
omikron auf der intensivstation und ich
habe wenige mittel zur hand wo ich das
beeinflussen kann das ist ein solches
mittel von daher ist sie haben mit dem
anliegen denn recht aber ich versuche
das so zu erreichen aber auch der
zweimal geimpfte kann sich dann nach
drei monaten anstecken und auch die oma
in den versuch mit der booster impfung
zu erreichen sie haben richtig also die
immunologisch sollte sich jeder der die
infektion durchgemacht hat sowieso noch
mal impfen gerade es ist die
hybridvariante und das ist dann die
aller sicherste wie wir verstanden haben
und noch mal die frage würden sie jetzt
alles zusammen nehmen sagen herr wetzel
es wäre gut bei den sechs monaten zu
bleiben oder ist deutschland gut beraten
zu sagen wir sind da sehr fest und
verhalten ist kommunikativ einfach ein
problem weil ich wirklich so sähe wenn
wir sagen gut nikon hat die spielregeln
verändert wir müssen bei genesenen die
nur einmal die infektion durchgemacht
haben nach drei morde an sagen du bist
nicht mehr ausreichend geschützt um dein
g status zu bekommen kommt also nicht
mehr geschäfte rein und etc dann muss
man das konsequente auch fragen für
leute die nur einmal geimpft sind oder
auch leute die zweimal geimpft ist auch
schon drei monate her ist das mag ich
natürlich nicht ich möchte ja die leute
wirklich ermuntern dass sie sagen ich
hole mir die ganze impfung ab und ich
muss zwischen der zweiten oder dritten
impfung nicht nur drei sondern
idealerweise vier oder fünf monate war
von daher wäre ich dafür dass wir sagen
gut dann genesenen status gilt wegen mir
noch diese sechs monate du hast einen
gewissen schutz vor schweren verlauf
aber bitte seid ihr auch klar du musst
dich auch impfen lassen und wenn du das
nach drei vier oder fünf monaten macht
wunderbar aber spätestens nach 6 uhr
schluss aber das findet auch nicht das
findet doch wir sehen doch dass es nicht
stattfindet und wenn ich jetzt ich muss
eben bei so etwas muss man immer ehrlich
sein und ehrlich ist ich weiß das denn
nach drei monaten nicht wirklich noch
vor einer infektion geschützt ist und er
kann die großmutter anstecken wenn ich
das weiß kann ich als minister nicht
sagen
ich denke jetzt statt täglich wenn ich
ihm die sechs monate lasse und er lässt
sich daneben finden erstens tut das
nicht und zum zweiten dann denke ich um
die ecke ich bin dafür verantwortlich
war zu sagen noch her wieder wir müssen
war sage nach den drei monaten ist
schluss
nochmal fragt heute berg sie holen tief
luft ich finde es ist ganz wichtig dass
wir einerseits erwartet von sehr richtig
gesagt pragmatisch unter
berücksichtigung der wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnisse die wir haben handel und
wichtig ist doch dass wir freiheit so
wenig wie möglich und so viel wie nötig
um des gesundheitsschutzes willen nur
einschränken und dann finde ich es
wichtig gerade um die akzeptanz für
maßnahmen zu erhalten dass wir
tatsächlich einen nachvollziehbaren
maßstab haben und deshalb ist die frage
was ist das ziel wenn wir maßnahmen
ergreifen grundrechte einschränken und
wenn es ist die hospitalisierung im
intensivbereich zu vermeiden überlastung
des gesundheitssystems dann ist es mir
sicherlich recht da muss man es da da
muss man dabei auch mal bleiben oder
nachvollziehbar zum beispiel auch bei
nikon die regeln ändert auch bei den
richtigen indikatoren bleibend oder die
wechseln zum beispiel zu sagen
irgendwann ist nicht mehr diese sieben
tage incident sondern die
hospitalisierung rate oder die intensiv
belegung der indikator in dem wir unsere
maßnahmen ausrichten müssen und das
übrigens am besten auch noch mit
aktuellen und aussagekräftigen zahlen wo
wir haben wir jetzt nicht also war er
sowohl verfassungsrechtliche als auch
von politischer klugheit damit
bürgerinnen und bürger bei der stange
bleiben und sagen wir halten die
maßnahmen auch für nachvollziehbar wir
halten uns an die regel nur dann kommen
wir ja auch wirklich aus so kennen wir
aus wir sind wir merken uns jetzt
lauterbach dass sie immer einsamer
werden hier am tisch mit den drei
monaten aber auch das ist ein schlechter
tag sie sagen das ist medizinisch
begründbar und ich möchte dabei bleiben
wir geben ihr habt die frage nicht
vergessen noch mal den ball nach köln
und fragen noch mal diese fußball frage
was soll der bürger damit anfangen
genau also fast ja eigentlich perfekt zu
dem was wir gerade gesprochen haben wenn
unterschiedliche regeln in verschiedenen
bundesländern im hinblick etwa auf die
fußballspiele erlassen werden dann kann
das durchaus eben damit zusammenhängen
dass wir unterschiedliche situationen im
hinblick auf das pandemische geschehen
in dem jeweiligen bundesland haben und
auch die sonstigen bedingungen also etwa
wie ist die krankenhaus auslassen wie
viele kliniken gibt es überhaupt wie es
allgemein das pandemische geschehen also
das sind alles eben fragen die daneben
berücksichtigt werden müssen wenn wir
uns die frage stellen wie weit sollen
wir das begrenzen um etwa die den
kollaps oder die überlastung des
gesundheitssystems zu vermeiden insofern
ist eine ungleichbehandlung zwischen den
ländern für sich genommen jetzt erst mal
nichts an dass wir
personen die sich schon was anderes als
um einen 20 750 schon was anderes als
25.000
ja nun bin ich natürlich auch an
juristin und bin auch darauf angewiesen
dass entsprechende studien geleistet
werden und wie wir tatsächlich in
solchen fußballstadion ein
erheblicher beitrag zum pandemischen
geschehen geleistet wird es ist im
freien das spricht für mich nach dem was
ich bis dann gelernt habe erst mal dafür
dass das risiko nicht ganz so groß ist
auf der anderen seite wird gesungen das
ist aber letztlich nicht mehr mit jeder
müssen wir uns eben darauf verlassen
dass die studien uns dann entsprechende
information liefern und so muss das dann
auch gerichtlich überprüft werden und
dann wissen wir immer noch nicht wie wir
hans joachim watzke helfen herr
lauterbach der sich jetzt rein klagen
möchte zweig zweig plus wackeln das
wackelt vor gerichten auch können sie
diese dinge ich sag jetzt mal ganz
salopp können sie die einfach ignorieren
dass gerichte das jetzt in der jetzigen
lage kassieren was ignorieren denn
natürlich nicht aber zunächst einmal
geklagt und das ist vollkommen in
ordnung werde in deutschland immer und
die handy also gerichte
urteilen jahr in unterschiedlichen
bundesländern ganz unterschiedliche
aufgaben muss es sein die bevölkerung so
gut zu schützen wie geht wir wollen auch
durch diese welle durch kommen mit
möglichst wenigen sterbefällen mit ohne
überlastung des gesundheitssystems und
danach richte ich meine regeln aus dass
der ein oder andere also aspekten von
den gerichten beklagt auch vor den
gerichten beklagten dort auch hier mal
oder damals kippten damit müssen wir
klarkommen aber was ich mir einfach
wünschen würde wäre ist deutschland ist
im vergleich zu anderen europäischen
ländern wir haben eine ganz alte
bevölkerung 23 die bevölkerung in europa
wir sind ganz gut dadurch jetzt
irgendwie durchzukommen das möchte ich
auch dass meine aufgabe dafür wird
gekämpft auch wenn das gericht das ein
oder andere von uns weg gibt und dann
müssen sie gegebenenfalls ihr aber auch
anders entscheiden weil die länder ist
auch anders entscheiden und es auch
anders entscheiden dürfen worüber wir
hier zu lande und darüber müssen wir
noch reden nun auch heftig streiten ist
eine impfpflicht einige menschen haben
diese impfpflicht wie gesagt schon vor
sich und vor dem geistigen auge weil sie
zum 15 dritter kommen wird nämlich die
einrichtungs bezogene und wieder die
situation ist schauen wir uns mal die
impfpflicht für pflegekräfte und
medizinisches personal kommt stichtag 15
märz im sächsischen bautzen wird auch
dagegen jede woche protestiert
neu ist dass kommunalpolitiker wie cdu
vize landrat udo wiemers positionen der
demonstranten übernehmen
ich kann ihnen sagen warum es bei uns am
16 das betretungsverbot nicht geben wird
wer soll sich um diese pflegebedürftigen
kümmern wenn sie nicht mehr da sind
inzwischen hat die landesregierung den
aufmüpfigen landrat zurückgepfiffen
im norden hat manuela schwesig post von
ihren gesundheitsämtern bekommen sie
seien nicht in der lage die impfpflicht
für beschäftigte in der pflege zu
kontrollieren
selbst der bayerische
gesundheitsminister zweifelt an der
fristgerechten einführung mit dem märz
wie wird was kontrolliert wie wird die
versorgung auch weiter sichergestellt
ist eine ganz zentrale frage ich höre da
gerade aus dem ambulanten bereich dass
das große schwierigkeiten gibt
wesentliche fragen im vollzug dieser
impfpflicht beklagen nun wieder die
bayern andere ministerpräsidenten warnen
her frei vor dem personalschwund denen
das bedeuten kann warum fällt das alles
eigentlich erst jetzt auf haben sie eine
erklärung dafür also zunächst einmal
habe ich viel verständnis dafür dass es
in den einrichtungen in den
gesundheitsberufen auch in den
ambulanten einrichtungen solche
befürchtungen gibt aber man muss auf der
anderen seite auch sehen wir haben dort
eine durchimpfungsquote die weit über 90
prozent liegt dh die allermeisten haben
das auch gemacht und wenn wir in andere
länder schauen wie in frankreich dann
haben dort die wenigsten in den
gesundheitsberufen geklärt in der
impfpflicht gekündigt und ich glaube
eines ist auch ganz entscheidend die
frau um salz gehört davor hin darauf
hingewiesen unsere verfassung
verpflichtet uns ja auch gleiches gleich
und ungleiches ungleich zu behandeln
und wir haben eben die situation dass
wir ab einem höheren alter eine deutlich
höhere gefahr dafür haben dass man bei
einer infektion dann auch ins
krankenhaus muss intensiv behandelt
werden muss beatmet werden muss und
deswegen bedarf dort eines besonderen
schutzes wer also mit gefährdeten
menschen arbeitet oder ist auch selber
ist der muss natürlich anders vor sorgen
als jemand der nicht in einem solchen
umfeld arbeitet und deswegen halte ich
es für
verfassungsrechtlich aber auch für
politisch geboten da sei ihm und rechts
hat es so zu machen weil bei jedem
grundrechtseingriff immer auch zu prüfen
ist wie kann ich das grundrecht schonend
machen wie kann ich das verhältnismäßig
so und jetzt haben wir aber herr wetzel
on economic ron ändert ein bisschen das
spiel ist diese mikrowelle dann
vielleicht vorbei wenn die pfleger dann
mit dem märz kündigen oder gekündigt
werden hoffentlich ist die amicom fälle
dann am abebben ob sie dann ganz vorbei
ist es weiß ich aber
aber bei nikon sehen wir ja aktuell dass
sich halt auch geimpfte infizieren
können und von daher muss ich ganz klar
sagen ja es ist absolut sinnvoll dass
leute die in pflegeberufen und den wir
sonst das system arbeiten geimpft sind
persönlich finde ich ehrlich gesagt dass
diese einrichtung bezogen impfpflicht
gar nicht weit genug geht dann sondern
weil sie hätte eigentlich die bewohner
einschließen müssen ja also wenn ich in
ein pflegeheim bin und da arbeitet wo
sich impft sein wenn ich da wohne muss
ich nicht wobei die leute die da wohnen
wirklich das hohe risiko tragen die
sollten idealerweise auch alle geimpft
und dafür haben die meisten residenzen
und pflegeheime natürlich auch gesorgt
wer in einem altenheim putzt oder der
hausmeister es muss genauso geimpft sein
ist das das ist ein grund ist dass das
eigentliche problem dass auch diese
menschen ich habe ganz früh in der
pandemie aufklärung auch bei für den
bundesverband pflegekräfte gemacht weil
da halt die leute waren die sich als
erstes mit zu impfen lassen konnten und
da haben ja auch viele leute gesagt es
ist gar nicht so dass die pflege denn
wirklich nicht geimpft sind eher die
leute die da als putzkraft oder als
hausmeister arbeiten also die pflegenden
haben eigentlich schon diese
verantwortung übernommen die meisten
davon haben sich impfen lassen von daher
glaube ich auch nicht dass wir den
großen expo für kommen aber es ist
natürlich nur konsequent wenn dann auch
der hausmeister und die reinigungskraft
auch nicht ganz genau so oder so wird
herr lauterbach kommt die frage jetzt
wird interessanterweise zu mitte februar
angekündigt dass der tod impfstoff auch
für das personal pflegepersonal zur
verfügung gestellt werden soll ich sehe
sie schon schmunzeln woher wissen wir
eigentlich dass genau das zahlenmäßig
belegt etwas ist was dann die noch nicht
geimpften pfleger pflegerinnen
angestellten imports von unternehmen
also sein
zahlen gibt es dazu nicht aber es gibt
sehr viele sogenannte anekdotische
evidenz wir bekommen am 21
ja dinge die uns mitgeteilt werden von
spezialisten die also roben gefragt
haben ob wir haben schon
liebe juristen
damit muss man ja auch arbeit und das
ist auch ein begriff in der medizin in
dem zünder das so wendig fallbeispiele
gehabt habe abfälle gesehen da denke ich
ist das ein muster uns weiter und wir
bekommen am 21 februar bekommen wir 1,4
millionen dosen von nowaks und dann die
woche drauf also aus der neunten
kalenderwoche nochmal eine million damit
kann man schon arbeiten das geben wir
das heißt wir sie das
gesundheitsministerium gegeben dass
ausschließlich an die länder es geht
nicht an die praxen und die länder also
können das dann nutzen um die
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht sammer
zu beschleunigen und aus dem umfeld hört
man dass viele auf diesen impfstoff dort
warten aber ich bin fest davon überzeugt
dass es in der regel nicht die
pflegekräfte sind die sich hier
verweigert wurde das ist wirklich also
darüber dass da werden die pflegekräfte
immer vorgeführt die pflegt viele
radikale eben nicht vorliege rische
bereich ist also der über den man sich
sorgen genauso nicht pflegerischen
bereich also beispielsweise die
hausmeisterei die küche und zu weiteren
reinigungsdiensten da wird dass er eine
rolle spielen das sind auch menschen auf
die die sagen wir von unseren kampagnen
nicht so gut erreicht worden sind aber
was ich glaube die also impfgegner und
querdenker die täuschend vor als wenn es
die pflegekräfte wären die sich jetzt
hier wären und angst vor ihr und körper
haben uns vor das glaube ich das gar
nicht der fall sie wären damit dem
nutzer wachs impfstoff werden wir noch
also etwas reißen da wären wir noch was
also schaffen aber ich glaube dass das
problem lösbar ist und also wir sollten
auf keinen fall von der einrichtungs
bezogen endlich abstreifen sie wollen
sie auch nicht verschiedene dabei
monatlich geben nein das habe ich den
antrag also der länder habe ich dort
kategorie haben wir nicht zugestimmt
also und nun gibt es noch weniger
personal das ist zu befürchten es wird
eben eine zahl von menschen wird sich
verabschieden und wird kündigen oder
gekündigt werden oder zeit befristet
irgendwie pausieren
meinen sie dass man das als gesellschaft
einfach so hinnehmen kann ein
bürgermeister kann sie auch nicht
hinnehmen ich glaube man muss sich damit
auseinandersetzen wenn es da probleme
gibt ich habe zum beispiel übrigens
hohen respekt vor den menschen die jetzt
die gespräche zu führen haben das ist
nicht einfach für die jeweils
zuständigen die vorgesetzten die noch
mitarbeiter jetzt überzeugen müssen oder
vor dieser frage stehen ob sie denen
dann attestieren sie unbedingt weiter zu
brauchen oder man sich trennen muss im
konfliktfall wenn das nicht gelingt
jemand zu überzeugen wichtig ist mir
aber vor allem erwerben vorhin über die
pcr test gesprochen über die notwendige
entscheidung bei knappheiten dass man da
dort priorisiert dass man bei menschen
mit hohem risiko in pflegeeinrichtungen
dann bevorzugt die pcs einsetzt genauso
ist es mit der frage wo setzen wir
welches mittel ein herr frey hat gerade
gesagt wir müssen auch ungleiches
ungleich bahnen auch das fordert unser
gleichheitsgrundsatz in der verfassung
da ist mir nur wichtig dass wir auch da
konsequent bleiben und in dieser
verfassung logisch
nachvollziehbar bleiben was her leider
passiert insofern würde mich
interessieren wie die union jetzt
dauerhaft zusteht ist dass herr söder
und herold check in bayern es sich jetzt
einen schlanken fuß machen insofern und
die logik umkehren und sagen weil es so
schwer ist mit einer einrichtung
bezogenen impfpflicht die wir aus guten
gründen des schutzes wohl näher am
menschen beschlossen haben sind wir für
die islanders die allgemeine pflicht und
in unserem verfassungsstaat das ganz
wichtig wir brauchen nachvollziehbare
begründungen warum wir in rechte
eingreifen und das darf nicht ein mittel
der erziehung oder um ein signal zu
setzen oder um es sich leichter zu
machen sein sondern man muss dann bei
der logik und bei der nachvollziehbaren
begründung auch bleiben wenn die
begründung ist dass das das mildere
mittel ist und meine dame den bereich
abdeckt der besonders sensibel ist
besonders gefährlich für infektionen
dann ist das umgekehrt darf man es nicht
danach zu einem argument für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht bleiben da machen
da bleibt man sich nicht treu und dann
das kostet glaubwürdigkeit
söder fragen und sind in köln bei frau
rostalsky der landrat in bautzen sprach
von einem berufsverbot das ähnlich mit
umsätzen
wolle
man kann das berufsverbot nennen de
facto ist es das aber nicht also jemand
der den ic fahren will der machten
sehtest das ist völlig klar und man
könnte jetzt auch sagen jemand der so
eng mit risikopatienten zu tun hat der
muss dafür sorgen dass er keine gefahr
ist
ja also eine voraussetzung für die
ausübung des berufs aus meiner sicht
müssen wir hier sicherlich auch punkte
praktiken die hier frei eben schon
genannt wir haben es hier mit einer
personengruppe zu tun die besondere
verantwortung hat und zwar gegenüber
menschen die besonders verletzlich sind
und aus seiner verantwortung hören auch
pflichten erwachsenen sich selbst in
besonderer weise zu schützen um wiederum
andere eben auch als fremdschutz das
weiterzugeben nichtsdestotrotz würde ich
davor wagen diese durchsetzungs
schwierigkeiten die wir jetzt schon
sehen herunterzuspielen es selbst wenn
es nur in anführungsstrichen nur
personal in der küche oder hausmeister
reihe betrifft sind das auch teile einer
einrichtung die von relevanz sind und
die für das gesamte schiff auch für das
funktionieren davon beiträgt naja
ansicht nach müssen wir das ernst nehmen
was ich da jetzt schon abzeichnet
und es ist für mich ein punkt der auch
wichtig ist bei der beurteilung der
rechtfertigung einer solchen maßnahme
kommt noch was anderes haben es ja hier
kommt noch was anderes entschuldigung
wäre ebenso
danke ich wollte noch anfügen dass wir
ist ja hier bei den bei dem
pflegepersonal mit personen zu tun haben
die in den letzten 24 monaten ja
besonders viel für unsere gesellschaft
geleistet haben sich besonders
eingesetzt haben viele menschen das
leben gerettet haben und da ist es eben
weswegen ich auch als fairer als
ethikrat darüber entscheiden was für
mich enthalten habe im hinblick auf
diese stellungnahme da ist es eben auch
etwas suchen als gesellschaft fragen
müssen ob wir das noch aufbürden wollen
wir das noch als zusätzliche
verantwortung abverlangen das ist finde
ich also politisch als auch rechtlich
nicht ganz einfach zu beantworten
morgen wir hier die politik noch einmal
er frei interessant ist die waren lange
bürgermeister von donaueschingen und
dann kann man sehr sehr konkret machen
wir sind noch mal bei dem landrat dem
stellvertretenden landrat cdu von
bautzen
die sache die da aus mecklenburg
vorpommern kam ist auch ein hilferuf wer
hilft denn in so einer situation wenn
die leute sagen die haben dann so wenig
personal und dann können wir nicht mehr
sicherstellen dass das heim zu betreiben
ist wer hilft ja also zunächst einmal
muss man natürlich bei allem respekt
sagen dass alle staatlichen behörden und
das ist auch ein bürgermeisteramt oder
im landratsamt die gesetze zu befolgen
und durchzusetzen hat das ist zunächst
mal vor die klammer gezogen und dann
will ich es mir natürlich auch nicht zu
einfach machen die politik darf auch
keine gesetze machen die nerven nicht
administrierbar und nicht umsetzbar sind
und deswegen wird man das im einzelfall
sich anschauen müssen aber das problem
halte ich für lösbar es ist
anspruchsvoll gar keine frage aber es
ist richtig hierfür einen besonderen
schutz zu sorgen und erwarte ich teile
ihre auffassung gerade bei der frage des
sektorspezifischen der
sektorspezifischen impfpflicht hätte man
durchaus darüber nachdenken können das
sogar noch auf andere bereiche mit
einigen etwa die die mit kindern
arbeiten von inzest hinterher dann die
kritische infrastruktur beispielsweise
wenn sie polizei feuerwehr ansprechen
bei der bundeswehr haben wir es gemacht
da hat man das einfach in die liste der
zu dulden den impfungen aufgenommen als
eine voraussetzung für die
berufsausübung eben das hätte ich mir
durchaus vorstellen können weil es das
ganze jahr immer unter dem ober satz zu
erfolgen hat was müssen wir tun um die
funktionsfähigkeit des gesundheitswesens
aufrecht zu erhalten das ist das ziel
des autors bundesverfassungsgericht
jetzt mehrfach in seinen entscheidungen
als legitimes ziel all dieser
schutzmaßnahme ok und trotzdem noch
einmal wir sind sofort bei der
allgemeinen impfpflicht erwarte ich frag
doch mal wenn ein pfleger der dreifach
geimpft ist jetzt dennoch einen älteren
menschen anstecken kann weil er nicht
vor einer selbst infektion sozusagen
geschützt ist lohnt dann dieser konflikt
indem wir gehen wenn wir menschen mit
dieser pflicht ausstatten das ist ja
eigentlich die schwere der frage ja aber
ich glaube man darf nicht vergessen dass
auch für einen 30-jährigen die impfung
sicherer ist als ich dem risiko der
infektion auszusetzen deshalb hätte ich
mir auch weisung landrat gewünscht dass
er nicht einfach sagt wir kriegen jetzt
ein problem sondern erst versucht das
problem zu lösen das problem löst sich
dadurch nicht dass ich das gesetz
einfach stur durchsetze sondern dass ich
auch mit informationen in diese richtung
rhein gehen dass ich leute sagen warum
habt ihr denn so eine angst vor dieser
impfung noch am leben ist eine so
kategorisch ab weil rein nüchtern
betrachtet aus geologischer sicht ist es
so die impfung ist viel sicherer als ich
dem risiko oder infektionen ausgesetzt
und dann muss man einfach auch mit
informationen und aufklärung natürlich
genommen und dann kann man nicht einfach
nur sagen das ist jetzt das gesetz das
gilt sondern das ist auch vernünftig
deshalb macht ja auch sinn die frage war
ja ob die impfung sich lohnt weil er die
bewohner dort trotzdem einschicken das
risiko dass jemand sich infiziert und
dann sich so stark infiziert die
bewohner anzustecken ist für den
geimpften viel geringer klar ich wollte
mal fragen damit wir es alle verstehen
wir sind bei der allgemeinen im
pflichtteil lauterbach sie haben sich
als abgeordneter gestern zu wort
gemeldet sie haben weder als
abgeordneter noch als minister einen
eigenen vorschlag hingelegt da gibt es
die schöne these dass olaf scholz sie
zurück gepfiffen hat was soll sie ist
ursprünglich wollten sie wollten einen
vorschlag machen das haben sie
angekündigt und dann ist der
verpufft das habe ich auch schon gehört
dass ich dir einfach schlecht nicht sind
auch nichts hören wollten auch nie einen
vorschlag zur pflicht machen ja und ich
habe so genannten vorschlag zur pflicht
zu machen hat mich aber dann dagegen
entschieden weil sie jetzt nicht aus
ethischen gründen nicht aus ethischen
gründen einfach schlicht und ergreifend
also aus glaubwürdigkeit gründen wenn
ich wenn wir sagen das sind
gruppenanträge der abgeordneten und ich
trete da auf und nach einen eigenen
vorschlag und sage ich bin also ein
einfacher abgeordneter das damit komme
ich nicht wo ich somit also ich schließe
mich gerne wenn ein antrag davor liegen
weiß vorlegen man kann doch eine
gesetzesvorlage machen man kann dann die
diskussionen und die abstimmung
freigeben aber es ist ja sowieso ist
normal das ist ja sowieso aber wenn ich
das mal zu ende gedacht wenn ich jetzt
also
ich will nur die frage beantworten also
wenn ich jetzt auch so in einen eigenen
antrag entwickelt hätte ich sage mal den
antrag laut aber
allgemein noch nicht für die allgemeine
wir hatten wir zwar hätten einen so
antrag gemacht
frey wir noch mit dem bund gewesen und
ich hätte dann aber gesagt also ich
mache den antrag ich bin dann einfach
abgeordnete das wäre doch eine farce
gewesen also somit also kann ich mich
einem antrag anschließen wenn einer da
ist wenn porto berg zum beispiel ein
antrag war und er wird mich überzeugen
und sich auffällig wäre gewesen wenn die
regierung wenn sie etwas für richtig
hält auch im vorstand das anders das
versagen wenn wir als regierung
warum haben sie es nicht gemacht weil
wir uns dafür nicht entschieden haben
weil die ampel hat entschieden dass wir
das quasi nicht
aber der war nicht lauter möglich also
dass das ganze
nicht so hat mich ehrlich gesagt bisher
noch irgendwie irgendwo zugeflogen oder
pacht ist es ja keine entscheidung die
im bundeskanzleramt getroffen werden
kann oder auch von den ampel fraktionen
sondern die frage ob etwas eine
gewissensentscheidung ist das trifft
jeder abgeordnete für sich sind und das
entbindet sie als regierung aber nicht
einen vorschlag zu machen dafür sind sie
ja gewählt und das ist nicht richtig
wenn wir also als regierung ein thema
nicht aufgreifen wir machen kann gesetzt
dann ist es die aufgabe der abgeordnete
sind zu entscheiden machen werden dann
also brauchen wir jetzt eine regierung
für alles
wichtige
großen respekt und freue mich auch wenn
auch die kollegen in der union das sehr
ernst nehmen mit sicherungen wie sie
sich da entscheiden da gibt's ja noch
keine auch keine jetzt einheitliche
position oder einige haben das aber
ohnehin nur ein einziger antrag von
herrn kubicki anderes
eigentlich gar keine ansagen zum einen
wir haben in dieser zeit der pandemie er
zu wenig debatte und
parlamentsbeteiligung gehabt an vielen
stellen das ist das eine und zum anderen
also ein selbstbewusster bundestag ist
auch eine gute sache so sehr es
regierungs entwürfe geben kann ein
freies stimmt ja auch nicht dass bei
jedem gesetzgebungsverfahrens einen
regierungsvorschlag geben müsse das
unterscheidet uns den deutschen
bundestag auch von der situation im
europäischen parlament wo es eher ein
problem ist dass das die kommission
exklusiv das initiativrecht hat man kann
eben auch aus der mitte des parlamentes
verschiedene vorschläge machen es gab es
auch bei verschiedenen anderen themen
präimplantationsdiagnostik war auch an
medizin ethisches thema geordnete leben
und tod hinaus
regierungsfraktionen eigene eigene
gruppenanträge gemacht haben insofern
wir sind damit vertraut in unserer
bundesrepublikanischen demokratie und
deshalb hat jeder die möglichkeit sich
jetzt an diesem prozess zu beteiligen so
wir haben jetzt nicht mehr so richtig
viel zeit nochmal ganz pragmatisch
gefragt herr wetzel ich fange mit ihnen
an
es gibt genug andere länder genug andere
beispiele wo innerhalb von wochen
entschieden wurde dass man nicht nur
einrichtungs bezogene und risikogruppen
bezogene im pflichten macht sondern sie
auch ab über 50 in italien zum beispiel
anführt in österreich gibt sie jetzt
auch als allgemeine impfpflicht sogar
und das ist einigermaßen schnell
entschieden worden es kann ja eine ganz
praktische und pragmatische frage sein
so etwas als regierung für wichtig zu
erachten haben die leute noch das gefühl
dass diese regierung eine impfpflicht
für wichtig erachtet ich glaube schon
weil ich glaube man muss ja ganz klar
sagen die impfpflicht wird uns ja jetzt
bietet mit dieser armee konnte nicht
helfen die die die begründung für die
impfpflicht auch für mich selber ich war
lange zeit dagegen aber mittlerweile
sehe ich keine andere möglichkeit mehr
wenn wir mit dieser im fluge die wir
haben als wir haben eine über 60
jährigen zehn prozent rund die nicht
geimpft die nicht immun sind in über
zwei millionen menschen die sich
infizieren haben wir ein großes leben in
den gesundheitsdaten häusern und wenn
wir mit dieser impflücken in den
nächsten winter gehen müssen wir wieder
maßnahmen ergreifen das will keiner dass
wir dich nicht ich habe langsam keine
lust mehr darauf was haben die meisten
leute nicht und von daher müssen wir
diese im fluge schließen ich habe es
lange zeit mit aufklärung versucht ich
bin von der impfung überzeugt aber man
braucht diese allgemeine impfpflicht
würden wir gerne ausprobieren aber wenn
es irgendwann nicht mehr reicht muss ich
die allgemeine impfpflicht auch predigen
gerne wir haben nirgendwo erhöhung der
impfung
ist das ziel das ist ja das ziel heißt
dass wir im flüge geschlossen wird also
ja aber das erreichen sie ja nicht
automatisch durch nicht sondern sie
müssen dann ja wir haben ja dadurch dass
es kein ins register in deutschland gibt
wissen wir ja noch nicht mal beschimpft
und wer ungeimpft ist das heißt sie
haben gar niemanden den sie ansprechen
können und dann sind wir uns ja
weitestgehend einig dass es keinen
impfzwang geben darf das heißt sie
limitieren die durchsetzung und deswegen
die fragen müssen geklärt werden sonst
macht man eine impfpflicht mit einem
ergreifenden europarechts eingriff ohne
am ende auch das ziel zu erreichen
werden kann er endlich durchsetzen ohne
im register und ohne impfzwang und wenn
sie so etwas sagen das geht nur mit
impfzwang und ins register dann sagen
wir wollen es nicht weil es ist das sind
etwa sind totschlag 52 habe ich alles
klar positioniert ein im register halte
ich für notwendig wir haben zum beispiel
auch nicht und es geht so ich bin nur
dass das hier kann das heißt die leute
also was in deutschland schrecklich ist
wenn man ein problem also nicht lösen
will dann sagt man aus dem mund nehmen
konnte
das hört sich nicht
der grund weshalb die die verschiedenen
befürworter einer impfpflicht der noch
keine konkreten anträge vorgelegt haben
es gibt ja auch nur so eine
absichtsbekundung jetzt einige
kolleginnen und kollegen einen antrag
für eine allgemeine impfpflicht
vorzulegen aber konkrete vorschläge
haben wir ja noch nicht und das ist kein
zufall dass das so ist diese umsetzung
so ist er halt schweiz probleme man weiß
auch nicht wie viele irgendwie und die
sind übrigens auch nicht nur eine
nachgelagerte frage sondern die
beeinflussen schon die verhältnismäßig
einheimisches vorschlages weil die frage
der umsetzbarkeit und durchsetzbarkeit
beeinflusst die wirksamkeit wenn wir uns
einig sind dass wir eine hohe impfquoten
erreichen wollen um den
gesundheitsschutz zu verbessern dann
erreichen wir das nicht durch ein paar
buchstaben im bundesgesetz umsatz
sondern darum dadurch dass sich menschen
real impfen lassen und wenn und das
sagen die meisten kolleginnen und
kollegen dass sie keinen zwang wollen
dann werden sie menschen die sich
hartnäckig der impfung verweigern also
schon mal nicht erreichen und dann
stellt sich für mich die frage wenn es
wirklich um lösungen geht wie erreichen
wir die menschen die sich hartnäckig
verweigern aber die wir noch nicht
erreicht haben das ist eine teilmenge
der einmündung ungeimpften und könnt da
habe ich zweifel nicht nur als juristin
verfassungsrechtlich an der
verhältnismäßigkeit sondern an der
klugheit und an der erfolgs trächtigkeit
dieser impfpflicht ob wir da nicht
anderes tun können um diese teilen die
lippenleserin erreichen und ein beispiel
übrigens kommunikation wir haben jetzt
die daten dass zum beispiel als im
sommer schon deutlich konsequenter und
früher 3g in italien frankreich
eingeführt wurde darüber nur zu reden
oder zweig gleich ins spiel zu bringen
das da zum beispiel noch die
freiwilligen impfungen signifikant
gestiegen sind einem kurzen zeitraum
aber sie sehen sie jetzt auch mit draghi
und mit der einführung der impfpflicht
m50 in italien sind auch die impfungen
gestiegen ja ich es gleich in europa die
allermeisten unserer nachbarstaaten
haben keine impfpflicht und man kann da
unterschiedlicher meinung sein aber ich
finde wir haben vieles nicht ausgereizt
und wir müssen einfach auch sehen
welches signal sendet die wenn sie
überwiegend nicht durchgesetzt wird wir
sehen das
muss jetzt ganz schnell auf die uhr
gucken und mich entschuldigen voraus
teil ski ist auch gegen eine allgemeine
impfpflicht das kann sie sehr gut
begründen bei herrn watzl haben wir
schon gehört dass eben mal dagegen war
und mittlerweile dafür ist die union ist
auch noch nie so richtig entschieden
aber sie persönlicher frei sagen 50 wäre
möglich das wäre ein kompromiss den sie
sich vorstellen könnten ähnlich wie in
italien
dann ist die ganz praktische frage zum
schluss herr lauterbach könnten sie sich
italien endlich italienische
verhältnisse in deutschland könnten sie
sich 50 auch als einen kompromiss
vorstellen ich glaube dass wir später
ein kompromiss hinbekommen aber ich
halte die allgemeine impfpflicht genauso
wie herr wetzel dass das bevor zu
bevorzugen instrument war wenn wir sehr
viele ausfälle bei den jüngeren dann
also berichten uns die kritische
infrastruktur wieder zusammen dann haben
wir noch argumente nikolic somit als ich
muss ich muss jetzt nicht über einen
kompromiss nachdenken wenn es noch eine
gute lösung geben kann und sie würden
das instrument das instrument während
die krankenkassen oder das instrument
wären da wird ja gearbeitet ich glaube
dass die große hühner die gruppe hier um
also dagmar schmidt heike behrens
janosch dahmen vor henning partygästen
also da gesprochen habe ich glaube dass
in der nächsten woche schon sehr viel
konkreter werden weil wir als
ministerium müssen wir alle anträge
unterstützen und da wir wissen nicht ob
sie auch heute berg unterstützt haben
als wenn es daneben aber wir gehen wir
davon aus und geben dann schnell zum
markus lanz ich spreche jetzt auch ein
bisschen schneller der ist sofort in der
spur und hat heute unter anderem mit
vitali klitschko zu gast das ist doch
der kanal es lohnt sich dabei zu bleiben
also entschuldigung es ist ein toller
gast zu einem sehr traurigen thema
entschuldigung es ganz schnell machen
und dann ist es irgendwie auch nicht so
richtig hin gekommen wir sehen uns
nächste donnerstag wieder gleiche stelle
gleiche welle 22.15 kommen sie gut durch
die nacht und jetzt kommt markus lanz
[Musik]